so six year anniversary in LA in LA yeah
March much their lunch there yeah and
how does that feel seeing that you've
been blessed with with 27 acting credits
and yeah how does that feel it's it's
coming it's crazy you know I when I made
that sort of uh realization yesterday
that I was like office is my you know
god I've been in at like six years I
didn't think about that you know like it
was just sort of like wow you know I
made a lot of great people and you know
I've done some good stuff but it's like
it was more just like when I can't
believe six years have flown by so
quickly um but yeah I mean it is sort of
a crazy thing to think about like what
you know what I've been able to you know
be apart of in that time and uh yeah
it's it's sort of a night you know it's
a nice feeling I I think it's you know
of course you know sometimes you think
your worst critic you know so I'm like
me and did I they really do a lot of six
years you know like but no I I
definitely feel like you know every year
i've had my little goals and and and
with roadside in madison county that
that's sort of i don't know in a weird
way that those were much further off
goals in my my my like you know
producing films um because I one day one
of direct and I was like why I'm gonna
produce and you know I helped cast I
want to produce and then I'll direct ah
so I you know it was weird how it just
happened and they fell into my lap but
it sort of you know pulled in those
goals much sooner than I had ever
anticipated you know I didn't think I'd
moved to LA and within three years be
producing feature films and selling
feature films you know like that was not
on my plan you know on my radar but uh
yeah I'm very I'm just very grateful for
it you know I I'm very grateful that I
I've been here for for that amount of
time and have had only one way during
job and then I work for Apple for a
couple for a year you know one of the
retail stores you know and then that was
it you know and then I had full-time
work you know through disney and then
just all the other acting you know gigs
and then producing and and being
involved with that and that alone has
been so rewarding to me because it's
I've been exposed to such a wide range
of experience just through the creative
process as a producer and and you know
that that's a credit to my you know my
good friend Eric and and just him as a
as a director as well because I also
know friends who are producers on
projects and they're like oh you know I
haven't seen it yet or I'm not involved
with the editing or do like I'm watching
it with you for the first time at a
premiere you know and it's like that's
not my I would never sign up to be a
producer like that like never you know
um that's just not my interest like it
takes a lot of time to produce a film
and it's like I understand that I'm
committed to it but I want to put in the
time to like I don't just want a lofty
title as a producer you know I mean as a
name like that's not that's not what I'm
interested in um so I'm very grateful
that I've had that opportunity in that
you know Eric we all work that closely
together you know they're the three of
us on our two films at least up to this
point like it's been Eric as it
obviously the creative Daniels like the
is the financial side of our team you
know that the money guy you know the
focus on that and like the mainstream
you know um uh you know I guess
acceptance like he's always thinking
about well how would you know a bigger
crowd you know like plated so and then
I'm in the middle like balancing out the
two you know what I mean and we're all
very involved like I mean I've been very
involved in all aspects of the editing
and like the sound process and like the
composers and like any art work that
goes out the trailers like we all
collectively work on those things
together and and that's been very
valuable to me because it's taught me so
much about the entertainment business
you know I you know it's it's show
business right not just show so it's
taught me so much and then I'm able to
sort of make that connection of how I
fit in as an actor and it's just giving
me sort of uh I don't know just a
behind-the-scenes peek where even if at
the the the the simplest level it just
mentally lets me off the hook because I
know like there are so many factors that
go into this like so many beyond our
control um that I just need to show up I
need to learn my stuff show up for an
audition do my thing and then be out
with it you don't I mean like I don't
have to it's not
as um I mentioned it earlier you know
I'm not as attached to it because I know
like there's only so much I can do you
know so as long as I make sure I'm
focusing and doing those things giving
it my Meryl Streep moment you don't even
when I when I have it then that's it
that's all I can ask for you know you
know there are so many different players
that come in and have different
influences on the process that I didn't
put no before producing these films so I
feel very lucky in and you know 2010 so
yeah like three years after I got here
to be able to be in that position and I
feel like it's made a big difference you
know and even just relating to other
friends of mine who are not actors just
you know like other casting directors or
other producers or you know when we'll
talk and and and like you know just be
able to talk to them and not like a
awkward like your cats and director I'm
an actor how do I not make this about
that or awkward you know and just
talking about other things and I think
like you know it's all part of that you
know that relating the people is a big
part of that and I feel like you know
being exposed to different facets of the
game of the process makes me puts me in
a position where i can relate more to
people and two more people you know so I
I'm very thankful in six years to have
had experience
you